yesterday
yesterday the government took another step forward in a drift
that seems to have no possible return
to try to please its partners
independentistas
the director of the cni has been dismissed.
without a single explanation
and have communicated
with the embarrassing and shameful attitude
of someone who knows he is humiliating
to the institutions represented by
once again president sánchez
has had to choose between survival
government and state health
and as always
has chosen the path that he believes guarantees him
some more time in moncloa
regardless of price
that we have to pay for it